for uh most of the time that we've lived
on this planet earth our species
uh we lived in tribes that were rarely
bigger than about 150 people
it's only about 10 or 12 000 years ago
when we started farming
that we could maintain larger
populations than about 150 but from
tens of thousands of years it was only
about 150.
um and there is inherent uh challenges
and and values in living in groups
first of all we can look after each
other right this is why
no human being is good by themselves we
want to be in a try we want to be on a
team
because together we're really really
strong but individually we're junk
we can't solve complex problems or lift
heavy weights by ourselves but in teams
and groups were amazing
but there's still some problems so go
back historically
we're living in these austere times
food and resources are you know are
difficult to come by
[Music]
the hunters go out the gatherers go out
and they bring some food back to the
tribe we're all hungry
we all rush in to eat if you're lucky
enough to be built like a linebacker
you can shove your way to the front of
the line
but if you're the artist of the family
you get an elbow in the face
this is a bad system because you punched
me in the face this afternoon
odds are i'm not going to wake you and
alert you to danger tonight
bad system and so we evolved into
hierarchical animals
we're constantly assessing and judging
who's alpha
who's more senior in the social or the
formal hierarchy
so in an organization whether it's in a
company or
in the military we have a rank structure
so i immediately know who i show
deference to
i immediately know where i sit in the
pecking order
right but we do it all the time
sometimes it's based on our appearances
sometimes it's based on our
our intelligence or our strength it
depends on the culture you come from if
you're a wrestler
how strong you are if you're a scientist
how smart you are
right um but we're constantly assessing
and judging each other
and when we assess that someone is alpha
to us we voluntarily
step back and offer them preferential
treatment
right we do it all the time uh it's like
if
if steven spielberg were to walk in the
door you would hold the doors open for
steven spielberg
and then you'd go home and be like i
held the door up seamless billboard you
wouldn't advertise holding the door from
anybody else you know if you're if
you're
senior and you leave your coat in the
other room someone will go get your coat
for you
if you're junior you get your own coat
right right
there's certain perks to being higher in
the hierarchy which is why we all want
to move up
so anyway we assess that someone's alpha
to us and we voluntarily step back
and allow our alphas to eat first our
alphas get first choice of meat and
first choice of mate
though i may not get to get not get to
eat first
um i uh i get guaranteed food and i
don't get an elbow in the face
good system however
the group is not stupid the group
doesn't give
all of those perks to our alphas for
free
there's a deep seated social contract
there's an expectation
that when danger threatens the tribe
it's the person who's actually stronger
actually smarter actually better fed
who's going to rush towards the danger
to protect us
we're not stupid this is why we take
care of our alphas because our office
have a responsibility to take care of us
and this is the responsibility of
leadership
and this is where we not a single person
has a problem with our alphas getting
preferential treatment zero no one is
morally offended by
the idea that somebody more senior in
the pecking order
gets a higher salary no one is offended
by that
right um you may think they're an idiot
but we're not offended by the fact that
they're given certain perks because of
their position
however what offends us is if they're
willing to sacrifice us to protect their
perks
right we're not offended by a ceo who
gets a huge salary what offends us
is a ceo who's willing to have mass
layoffs
to protect their bonus that's what
offends us
because like i said the responsibility
of leaders
is to protect their people and if you
protect
protect us and we feel safe then we're
totally okay with you getting all those
perks
but it's it's a balanced equation and so
this is the anthropology of leaders
we we are a hierarchical species there's
no avoiding it
but there's a responsibility in that
hierarchy
you